after we have our gene expression table
now we want to compare different samples
or groups of samples in our data set to
do that we can first transform the raw
data into logarithmic scale and then use
quantum normalization a technique that
converts everything into a normalized
scale based on standard deviation units
and aligning the mean between samples so
that we can better detect differences
between samples and adjust for any kind
of technical variation that is due to
different lab preparation kits and even
the different sequencer settings when
the sequencing is being done let's see
how to do this practically on the
platform we have to go to utilities and
under utilities we can just upload our
gene expression table once we upload the
gene expression table we can click on
continue' start and you will find
quantum normalization right here since
we want to adjust the distributions we
will be aligning the means and making
everything more comparable in standard
deviation units you can read more about
quantum normalization in this link
before doing quantum normalization we
can transform the table to logarithmic
scale and we don't want to normalize
everything and we also want to set a
threshold so that we will normalize all
the values under the threshold of five
in logarithm scale units to check
whether we're getting a good result we
can also use PCA
to visualize how variance shows the
different samples in the data set make
sure that you carefully look at this
headings on the side because you don't
want to transform the values again to
normal logarithmic scale and of course
no filtering and some of these other
parameters are not going to be relevant
to what we are doing now that our
pipeline is done let's take a look at
the results you will get the zip file
with all of the results the results for
PCA and also your normalized table